wenn israelische Medien aus Gaza
berichten sieht man fast nur solche
Bilder Soldaten die vorwärts stürmen
Soldaten die erfolgreich die Hamas
bekämpfen israelisches Fernsehen und
Zeitungen berichten 24 Stunden 7 Tage
die Woche ausschließlich über den Krieg
man sieht nichts von Gaza es geh nur
die tapferen Soldaten die getöteten
Soldaten die Geiseln die Familien der
Geiseln und so weiter nichts über
Gaza im Schnitt wissen die Deutschen in
einem kleinen Dorf in Bayern viel mehr
über Gaza als wir Israelis die nur eine
Stunde von Gaza entfernt leben und die
verantwortlich sind für das was in Gaza
passiert und wir sehen nichts
davon Gideon Levi weiß wovon er spricht
er ist einer der erfahrensten Reporter
in Israel und berichtet seit vielen
Jahren für die Zeitung HRZ einmal die
Woche fährt er ins Westjordanland um
hier nach dem unrechten zu sehen und
davon gibt es
viel diesmal sind es 700 Schafe beim
kleinen Ort musaa die den ganzen Abgrund
des narostkonflikts aufscheinen lassen
so etwas wie Grenzen kennen die Tiere
nicht und so sind sie unerlaubt auf das
Gebiet einer jüdischen Siedlung geraten
israelische Polizei hat die Tiere fest
gesetzt und verlangt nun im Auftrag der
siedlerverwaltung 150 000 schäkelstrafe
von den mittellosen palästinensischen
Schäfern fast 40 000 € sonst werde man
die Tiere
beschlagnahmen wir kennen alle die
Wahrheit es geht nur um eine andere Art
und Weise die Schäfer zu tyrannisieren
damit sie das Land verlassen im Schatten
des Krieges in Gaza Unternehmen die
israelischen Siedler enorme
Anstrengungen um die Realität zu
verändern solange niemand
zuschaut die Schäfer verstehen nicht
dass sie sich nicht in dem Land frei
bewegen dürfen das eigentlich ihnen
gehört gestern war ich bei den Schafen
ein Siedler kam zu mir und wollte auf
mich schießen alles ist verboten es ist
verboten das Haus zu verlassen alles ist
verboten wohin soll ich gehen die
Menschen haben Angst Angst mich
persönlich werden Sie fragen weil ich
mit ihnen den Journalisten gesprochen
habe und man wird mich fragen warum ich
gesagt habe was ich gesagt habe ich bin
ein alter Mann 65 Jahre alt ich habe
keine Angst dass sie mich ins Gefängnis
stecken aber die Jugend hat
Angst Gideon Levi hat auch keine Angst
was ihm Sorge macht ist die Ignoranz
seiner
Kollegen es gibt ein Thema das die
israelischen Medien seit Jahren nicht
behandeln und das auch noch freiwillig
und ist
Besatzung und nicht dass ihnen jemand
befohlen hätte nichts darüber zu
berichten es ist nur weil sie wissen
dass ihre Leser und Zuschauer es nicht
sehen wollen es geht nur um kommerzielle
Kalkulationen sie wollen es nicht sehen
also werden wir sie nicht nerven und auf
diese Weise verraten sie die
grundsätzliche Aufgabe eines jeden
Journalisten die ganze Geschichte zu
erzählen wir erzählen nicht die ganze
geschichtei hält mit seinen Berichten
dagegen das macht sonstum denn gelobt
wird man dafür
nicht Leute wie ich werden als verrückte
gebrannt magt oder als Verräter nur
wegen der Tatsache dass wir über das
Leben dieser armen Menschen berichten
die nebenbei gesagt definieren was das
Regime Israels bedeutet das ist kein
Randgebiet hier das ist Israel das ist
das wahre Israel ich sage immer ich habe
das Privileg exklusiv zu sein ich bin
immer exklusiv nein im Ernst Israel lebt
in der
igerzuben die Besatzung auszublenden gar
nicht über die Besatzung zu berichten
nichts und nun sieht man das gleiche in
Gaza tatsächlich berichten israelische
Medien vor allem über den Vormarsch der
Armee in Gaza die gefallenen
Soldaten die Lage der
Geiseln
reg
Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza die Folgen des
israelischen Bombardements der Hunger
und das Leiden werden weitgehend
ausgeblendet anders als bei westlichen
Medien wie CNN BBC oder auch
ZDF R Drucker Moderator bei Kanal 13
redet nicht drum
herum wir werden nicht die Elenden Babys
von Gaza zeigen sterbend verwundet oder
verletzt und mit Blut im
Gesicht wirerden nicht interie mit der
armen Mutter bringen die gerade ihr Baby
verloren
hat das alles werden wir nicht zeigen so
ist die Realität ich will versuchen das
zu erklären ich denke es gab noch nie in
der Geschichte Israels eine Zeit
zumindest während der letzten 50 Jahre
in denen die israelischen Medien so in
die Pflicht genommen worden sind um
Israel zu helfen den Krieg zu
gewinnen doch was ist der Grund für dies
Selbstbeschränkung die flächendeckend
fast alle israelischen Medien erfasst
hat wir zeigen fast nichts vom Elend und
vom Leiden in Gaza man sieht nur sehr
wenig davon auf israelischen Bildschirm
zum Teil hat das technische Gründe weil
wir keine Reporter dort haben aber der
andere Grund ist dass die Leute es nicht
wissen wollen und sie wollen es nicht
sehen es ist nicht so dass sie es nicht
wüssten sie wissen es aber sie wollen es
nicht sehen sie betrachten das ganze als
wir oder
aber verstößt es nicht gegen
journalistische Grundregeln nicht über
die andere Seite zu berichten nicht über
die Menschen in Gaza und nicht über die
im
Westjordanland zunächst mal in diesem
Punkt haben Sie zu 100% Recht und dieses
Verhalten ist völlig
ungerechtfertigt ich habe auch keine
Entschuldigung dafür aber jedes Mal wenn
wir eine Geschichte in meiner 40
minütigen investigativsendung bringen
eine Geschichte über Fehlverhalten im
West
dann will das niemand
sehen das heißt frage ich der wahre
Grund ist dass es kein Interesse der
Öffentlichkeit dafür gibt sie langweilen
oder Nerven gar ihre Zuschauer wenn sie
solche Berichte
senden es ist noch viel schlimmer als
Nerven ich bin ein
Quälgeist es belästigt die Zuschauer sie
wollen es nicht sehen sie haben noch
nicht mal die Energie mich zu
beschimpfen sie gehen einfach nur auf
ein anderen Kanal oder lesen die Zeitung
sie wollen einfach nicht mehr über diese
Sache
Wissen der Journalist Ben linfield
kritisiert seit langem die schwarzen
Löcher der israelischen
Berichterstattung für ihn geht es auch
um den Verfall demokratischer Werte
unglücklicherweise haben die Menschen
professionellen Journalismus den Quoten
geopfert Meinung nach sind es die
nachrichtenmanager die entschieden haben
dass die Öffentlichkeit keine arabischen
Zivilopfer im Fernsehen sehen will und
dass das schlecht für die Quoten
ist wir wissen aber gar nicht ob die
Öffentlichkeit das tolerieren würde oder
nicht dennoch haben die Medienmanager
entschieden dass die Öffentlichkeit es
nicht toleriert dass es schlecht ist für
die Quoten und dass sie den Sender
wechseln
andere Beobachter sehen darin ein
durchaus natürliches Verhalten einer
Gesellschaft sie müssen verstehen dass
dieses Verhalten völlig normal ist wir
wollen grundsätzlich im Fernsehen sehen
was unseren eigenen Leuten angetan hat
unsere eigenen Brüder und Schwestern
wurden abgeschlachtet und vergewaltigt
sie wissen das war schrecklich ich
glaube nicht dass sich eine Nation im
Kriegszustand auf eine andere Art und
Weise verhalten sollte weil alles andere
Selbstmord
wäre auf palästinensischer Seite ist die
Situation noch viel schlimmer von den
Greueltaten der Hamas am 7 Oktober
erfahren die Gäste in den Cafés von
ramala wenig eine freie Presse gibt es
hier nicht und der arabische Sender
aljasira berichtet einseitig bis
unverholen als Propagandist der
Hamas der Elektriker Anas hamdam hält
sich für gut informiert die Gewalt der
Hamas sieht er zumindest teilweise
kritisch ich bin gegen alles was
Zivilisten betrifft wenn es zu
militärischen Aktionen kommt habe ich
kein Problem aber ich bin gegen alles
was gegen Zivilisten geschieht
Zivilisten haben damit nichts zu tun
genauso wie wir unschuldige in Gaza
haben dort gibt es auch Zivilisten ich
bin generell dagegen Zivilisten
anzugreifen doch angesprochen auf die
systematischen Vergewaltigung elt er ab
nein nein das stimmt nicht die Israelis
haben zunächst die sozialen Medien
benutzt und diese Gerüchte verbreitet um
die öffentliche Meinung im Westen zu
gewinnen doch dann wurde all dieses
Gerede widerlegt sogar die Geiseln
selbst sagen es ist nichts
passiert ein weitverbreitetes Urteil
obwohl die Beweise erdrückend sind es
heißt dass sie Frauen vergewaltigten
aber ein Muslim vergewaltigt nicht
selbst wenn er seinen Feind bekämpft das
ist Gesetz unser Prophet hat uns gesagt
du sollst keinen Baum fällen oder ein
Gotteshaus abreisßen und du sollst keine
Frau
töten das angeblich nicht passiert ist
was nicht passieren darf hängt nicht
zuletzt mit der dominierenden
Berichterstattung aljasiras zusammen ein
Interview mit dem ZDF lehnte der Sender
ab in der Wahrnehmung der Araber
erkennen selbst palästinensische
Meinungsforscher eine durchgängige
Fehlwahrnehmung
die meisten Palästinenser glauben nicht
dass die Hamas die Greueltaten begangen
hat die sie begangen
hat die große Mehrheit der Palästinenser
hat die Videos nicht gesehen die zeigen
wie die Hamas Greueltaten in den
israelischen Städten nah Gaza
begeht dennoch erachten die meisten
Palästinenser Angriffe auf Zivilisten
Frauen und Kinder als
Kriegsverbrechen und als Verstoß gegen
internationales Recht sie glauben nur
nicht dass die hamassu etwas getan hat
diejenigen die die Videos gesehen haben
die solche grultaten zeigen geben zehn
Mal häufiger zu dass die Hamas diese
grultaten begangen hat das macht also
einen
Unterschied andere sehen darin ein
weiteres Verhaltensmuster in der
arabischen
Welt das reflektiert ein viel tieferes
Problem in der arabischen und in der
muslimischen Welt
man kann die eigenen negativen Seiten
nicht im Spiegel betrachten Sie glauben
dass sie ein Engel sind sie können keine
Kriegsverbrechen been deshalb gibt es
nur zwei Verhaltensmuster wir sind
entweder die Guten oder wir sind die
Opfer dazwischen gibt es nichts und das
ist das
Problem schlechte Voraussetzungen für
die Kommunikation zweier verfeindeter
Völker die arabische Welt von freier
Berichterstattung
Israels Medien mit blinden
Flecken die Medien auf beiden Seiten
spielen eine negative
Rolle anstatt die Menschlichkeit der
anderen Seite zu betrachten
entmenschlichen Sie die andere
Seite Gideon Levi sieht die größantwort
auf seit
is er freien und demokratischen Presse
was bei den palästinensischen nicht der
Fall ist sie sind nicht so frei wie
unsere Medien deshalb ist unsere
Verantwortung so viel
größer und noch eines empört ihn ganz
besonders es ist nicht so dass wir eine
Zensur hätten es ist nicht so dass die
Regierung die Geheimdienste oder die
Armee uns Befehlen würden zeigen sie das
nicht es ist viel schlimmer als das weil
es freiwillig ist weil alles nur darum
geht nur die sensiblen Seelen unserer
Zuschauer und Leser zu belästigen ich
erinnere mich wie wir über die
russischen Medien gelacht haben als sie
über den Krieg in der Ukraine berichtet
haben was für ein Witz von Journalismus
Israels Journalismus in diesem Krieg ist
viel schlimmer warum weil wir es freiwi
willig tun sie haben das putinreime dass
sie nicht die Wahrheit erzählen lässt
die israelischen Medien wählen nicht die
Wahrheit zu erzählen und in meinen Augen
ist das viel
schlimmer Sache mit den Schafen konnte
übrigens geregelt werden jüdische
Menschenrechtsaktivisten zahlten die
150.000 Schäkel im voraus und lösten die
Tiere für die Schäfer aus aber selbst
von dieser menschlichen Geste zwischen
Feinden erfuhren nur ein paar Leser
eines einzelnen
Journalisten